[Music]  [Applause]  this is just fantasy  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  from reality  [Music]  I enjoyed the show I also write song  leasing it is quick and then you need  someone new and after we move up stage  room belongs to you don't you see what  you could be  no one will play us on the radio we need  to get experiments do it again  one more how many more Galileo's do you  want Roger there's only room in this  band for one hysterical Queen Matt these  words no one will play Queen fortune  favors the bold  Freddie concerning your private life  what more do you need to know I make  music I want to give the audience a song  that they can perform what's the lyric  ready Freddy  let's do  [Music]  you need to slow down Fred I just need a  bit of time what if I don't have time  [Music]  [Music]  you're letting the fresh we're all  legends  [Applause]  [Music]  you